-I'm so happy you're here.
-I am so happy.
I'm gonna say
straight off the bat,
you were fantastic
on the Golden Globes.
-That's very kind of you to say.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You were.
I was there as you know,
but I didn't get a chance
to give you a big hug
and say you were fantastic
whilst you were up and at 'em.
-Well, thank you so much.
We actually met in this building
in 2005
when you hosted
"Saturday Night Live."
Is it true that there's a sketch
you and I did together
that you still hear about
from people?
-I hear about it,
and I actually go on YouTube
or on the website.
-You watch it yourself
a few times.
-Because it makes me chuckle
because I remember you
that time.
That whole week was
one of the best,
most terrifying experiences
of my life.
But you were so instrumental
in that of making me feel calm.
And that sketch was one of
the funniest things
I've ever, ever, ever done.
-You brought me to a party with
your friends. We were on a date.
-We were on a date.
-That was a comedy joke.
[ Laughter ]
-And it was -- the party was
Bob Fosse-themed,
and I was the only person who
was not a Bob Fosse character.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it was really --
-It went from --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oopsie. Jazz.
-Yeah, jazz.
This is basically the character.
My only recurring character
on "SNL"
was a guy who was like,
"This isn't going well!"
[ Laughter ]
You've done theater.
Do you miss the theater?
Do you go see a lot of theater?
-Yes, to all.
I started in theater when I was
a little, little girl.
I was nine in "Annie,"
and I did "Bugsy Malone"
in like the Broadway,
in the West End in London.
And then I did a lot of theater
in Britain,
and then became TV and film.
And then I went back about six,
seven years ago to Broadway,
and I loved it.
I love, love, loved it.
And I always go to the theater.
I sit there, and I sit, and as
the play, or the musical starts,
it's like,
"I want to be up there.
I want to be up there."
So I'm just looking
for something --
I would love to do
something original.
Something that has never been
done before, you know,
so that would be great.
So I'm looking forward to that.
-You also --
You found this story,
this Griselda Blanco story.
You were drawn to that as well.
You kind of became
obsessed with her.
-I became obsessed with her,
yeah.
It's been three years of this
obsession with this woman.
-How did you come
to know about her?
-I saw a documentary called --
And it was a well done
and well-viewed documentary
called "Cocaine Cowboys."
And this woman
wasn't featured in it
because she had since passed.
But all these men,
these dark, very dangerous men,
some of them out of prison,
some of them still in prison
and never coming out of prison,
talked about this woman,
Griselda Blanco.
And they revered her.
They feared her.
And it was like, "Who was this
woman who was running --"
She was
the queen of these kingpins.
Pablo Escobar worked for her.
So, you know.
And she first of all,
she survived so long
at the top in this game
in the '70s in Miami,
where it was the height of
the drug industry.
And she was -- She was running
the show.
-You said she survived
for a long time.
Is it true that one of
the reasons,
like, there's very little tape
on her.
-I didn't see any tape of her
except some old footage after
she'd been deported to Colombia.
And she was in her older years
not long
before she was
actually assassinated.
And she was
in a small apartment.
She was very grandma-ish,
and she was, you know --
-That's how they get you.
That's how they get you.
-I said I don't believe that
for one minute
because this woman is an actor.
She had everything that we just
strive for, you know.
She was really screwed up
in many ways, but brilliant.
And she came from Medellin
in Colombia.
She became the head of
the drug industry in America.
And she just had so many
different layers
for me to play with, you know?
-Audiences tend to be drawn to
these stories about
the drug trade.
You were, I would argue, in one
of the greatest movies about it
of all-time -- "Traffic."
-Thank you.
-And why do you think it is
that audiences
are drawn to stories
like Griselda's?
-Myself being one of those
audiences, what is it that we --
I mean, I'm always, and I'm sure
this -- I mean what are we,
"Godfather 4?"
There's a fascination with
the under -- a darker world.
You know, a world that I'm never
going to be a part of,
but there's something --
-You don't know!
-I know.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't sell yourself short!
-Third time a charm as we say
in Ireland, you know?
Maybe the third one
will be real. No.
It's just that world, the
family -- the family, you know.
-And Griselda was like that.
She hid behind the fact that she
could justify what she did.
And it was pretty gruesome
at times for the family
just so her boys wouldn't --
you know, live the life
that she had to live.
I don't buy that either, Seth.
I really feel that
this woman was --
you know, she was a very
powerful, but on a power trip.
You know, she -- she --
she had it all.
And she was an addict.
So she had that addictive
personality,
and when she couldn't stop,
there was never enough money.
There was never enough greed.
There was never enough coke.
There was never enough sex.
There was never enough
of anything.
-You're telling my story.
You're telling my story.
-I know. I'm renaming it
the return of Seth Meyers.
-Well, you can play me hopefully
one day, too.
-I will play you.